you guys i'm gonna dive right in because
i have so many questions for you
how does it feel to be able to share
with the world that you are in love
i mean it's like a weight's been lifted
off our shoulders yeah absolutely
freedom
zach i know you're kind of new to the
bachelorette and bachelor world was it
hard for you to keep all this a secret
did you have to figure it all out
i think the overwhelming response from
my close circle
over the past you know 12 hours is that
i'm a vault like they're just like how
did you hold this in and i just
i mean facial laid it down and i
followed direction
good good job nip tough do not want to
say anything
now tasha show me that ring did that
ring ever accidentally make it into an
instagram or was that a different ring
i guess i could come clean now yeah it
accidentally did okay
what was that moment like a little scary
um i actually was freaking out i was
screaming i was running all throughout
the house
um he was with me obviously and it was
um
it was a panic but also at the same time
i kind of just played it off and kind of
just like went away
so i actually got to see her in crisis
so
you know crying had a good learning it
was like my first like okay
she that's all right okay so say
you almost spoiled your season uh maybe
i mean honestly who doesn't drink their
coffee in the morning and have a couple
diamonds on
i was just doesn't every girl do that no
yes you're just being a beautiful
icon that you are i love it um now tasha
i do got to ask you about you know all
these big finale moments
who said that ivan was the perfect guy
you said you saw yourself with brendan
you
you brought ben back into the fold i
think viewers were really wondering with
your season
how is this going to end so how did you
choose zach
how did you know that it was him when
you did seem to have major connections
with these other guys
you know at the end of the day it was
just like where
what i pictured my life looking like in
five ten like
20 years and like who i saw as like
possibly being the father of my children
and just
who was most compatible with me who
meshed well with my family there's so
many factors that go into it and
you know all the guys are amazing but i
just
i had a connection with zach that i
don't think i've ever really experienced
with anybody else and it just
you know sometimes you kind of want to
fight those feelings because it's too
good to be true but at the same time
like it was just
slapping me in the face essentially
you you seemed to say that a little bit
in that proposal moment last night that
it was beyond love
explain that how did you guys know that
this connection really was
it and hitting you right in the face
well i feel like
we felt it pretty early on sure yeah
but at the same time i feel like we were
both a little bit like
hesitant to acknowledge it just because
it's like hold on a second this is
happening way too fast like
are we really like you know is this real
is it just like the situation and um
i think it was like during his hometown
date that we were just like
it's undeniable and um
yeah it was kind of like screaming at us
at that point
yeah once once we got to the family
piece of it it was
it was on that made the difference zach
i wanted to ask you because you talked
about this
with your family you said i used to say
i wasn't
ready to get married and have kids or
maybe that i never wanted to
if you never wanted to get married how
did you end up on the bachelorette
that's a great question my uh
my little sister submitted an
application for me she was
pregnant with twins and uh she lost
one of the pregnancies so if i could
paint the picture it was probably
you know march or april and she's
sitting at home
and it's like deep depression anxiety
the whole thing and
lo and behold like casting for the next
bachelorette comes up and like in this
moment of just
like screw it i'm going to do this she
submits my application and
next thing you know i'm getting a call
from la i'm like who is this
wow so family really is behind a lot of
this love
yes i will tell you i did an interview
with noah and noah
said i don't really know how zack can go
from
never wanting to get married to suddenly
being ready to get married and have kids
and and he seemed to question that a
little bit so tell me
i tell the viewers how did you know that
you totally changed your mind on these
pretty big things
first of all i love noah he'll buy for
me
i guess the muscle's off i can say hi to
no um
i truly do he's an amazing man and uh
no i think it's one of those cases where
internally
you know i knew that i wanted to be a
father i knew that i wanted to have kids
i saw love growing up around me with all
my best friends but
there's a little bit of fear in saying
that out loud because i'm 36 years old
and i don't have those things yet so
like i said at the beginning having the
time to kind of reflect on that and then
meeting keisha it kind of put things in
perspective for me so
was it you putting up a wall because you
were worried you you weren't going to
have those things
yeah and that was part of it yeah that
was part of it and like
i think there was things about the
single life that i liked you know like
waking up on saturday morning just going
playing golf and not having to you know
like there's like
relationships are tough so uh well you
guys have been
in this bubble the two of you without
being able to share things for the with
the world
what has your relationship been like has
it been you know you've learned a lot
about each other what have you worked
through how these happy couple weekends
as they call them gone
they've actually gone pretty well but i
mean it hasn't been like
easy breezy the whole time i feel like
we just like any normal
relationship like we've had to learn how
to
communicate with each other kind of like
navigate when like you know some
someone's like feeling that high of
happiness and like someone's like not
there and they're
having a bad day at work or something
like that it's just you have to like
learn how to be with each other every
single day and i feel like even watching
the show back i can get difficult at
times for myself it could get difficult
for him and and we've had to navigate
all of those
situations as they come but it's been
really fun
would you say that yeah i mean it's not
natural right it's not natural and i
think
a large part of the world is
experiencing it with coven like all
these relationships are being forced
back into the home and
couples are kind of staring each other
like okay what do we what do we do now
zach you you just said okay one thing
was the single life and going to play
golf
are you missing it how you feeling being
in a relationship yeah why don't you
share with us
come on have i hit my emotions at all i
think i think it's pretty clear how i'm
feeling
you know the smile says it all well i'm
probably pushing you guys on this
because you didn't have an afr
because of the pandemic usually we'd get
this after the final rose and the fans
would hear how you are so
last night on twitter everybody was how
are they how are they doing
so i guess just yeah tell the audience
where are you at in this relationship
give me some adjectives how are you guys
feeling about each other
months after filming has ended
we're really freaking good i'm the
happiest i've been and i feel like
our relationship is just so different
than anything i've experienced and i've
you know um thought i would be blessed
to have and so
i'm i'm doing well i'm living my best
life yeah i'm
yeah i'm i echo everything she said and
i'm excited okay zach's learned how to
be in a relationship he's echoing
everything you've said about it i'm
doing well don't you think
yes is the answer well
uh you you said after your proposal
moment last night
that he's the guest and you're the
brakes so where are you guys at with
next steps
with uh planning a wedding with having
kids with
moving in together where is all that
you're the brakes i know i think that
surprised me that you said that i
thought it was the reverse i don't know
who's the gas and who's the brakes well
at first he said that he was the gas in
the beginning we first met each other he
was like
i need some breaks and i'm like i could
be the brakes for you but in reality
i'm the gas he is the brakes so that's
what i thought okay
yeah that's more like it we've figured
it out um
but as far as like the future and what
that holds
um we're just gonna just live our happy
engaged life we're gonna i'm gonna be by
coastal so i'm gonna be
in new york quite a bit um but also here
in orange county so that's really fun
and exciting yeah
what else oh yeah i mean we're gonna
she's gonna get to see the city and i'm
gonna get to see orange county and we're
gonna
just really take it slow but enjoy this
enjoy this like special time in our
lives and know that
you know without this solid foundation
and
you know learning all that there's to
learn about each other like
everything else will fall into place
yeah would either of you be willing to
move
across the country for the other
we've talked about it yeah of course
zach this must be wild for you your
first day of interviews and you're
talking about being engaged and stuff is
just so funny
you didn't even have like an interview
as a contestant at first
yeah we would go interview you on the
date or something you're just diving in
he really is you really i mean that's
kind of in this whole experience to be
honest i
uh kind of just showed up here um tasha
uh fans did have a big reaction again
going back to the episodes but to you
sending ivan home i think
they were shocked by it tell me what the
reasoning there was we heard a mention
of religion but i'll be honest i didn't
fully understand it
well i think like the beauty of like a
fantasy sweet day is that you have
that opportunity to really talk about
um things you might be shy about talking
in front of the camera and everything
like that like
really just diving to the nitty-gritty
of a relationship and what the future
could possibly look like and
sure religion was one of the reasons but
there was a multiple things that we
talked about
that you know i just um that
we just kind of didn't align on and um
at the end of the day when i was looking
at my relationships with
zach and and ivan it was just that i saw
my future with zachary and
and that's kind of like where my heart
led me and i can only just
lean into that and you know
unfortunately
um yeah that's just where how to end oh
she called you zachary
is that exactly zachary she does call me
zachary
tasha your dad is somebody who makes his
opinions known
how does he feel about zack and this
relationship
oh my gosh like i i don't think my dad
has really
um acclimated to someone as quickly as
he has to him like they
are he adores him and um i'm really
really happy about that because my dad's
a tough cookie to crack at times
yeah he's been really welcoming to him
that's awesome
and you know it was again fans were
really wondering how this was going to
end i even even said on his way home he
said he didn't think you were going to
choose anybody
i heard that that was interesting to me
is that last night yeah
yeah but tell me why it was interesting
to you was there
um i mean you you were kind of wondering
we saw you question things analyze
things
was there a moment where you ever
thought i just gotta leave here
single and and go from there you know
no but i also didn't like i didn't feel
like oh my gosh i have to go
but i um toyed with the idea in my head
like do i really feel like i'm happy do
i really like i'm getting somewhere
um i feel like you have to be open to
all possibilities and i feel like if you
were to
be like stress yourself out and be like
no i have to get engaged like are you
really doing it for
quote unquote the right reasons you mean
are you gonna be happy down the road
um but yeah that was interesting to me i
didn't expect that did you oh did you
think i'm ending up with this guy like i
mean i don't know
at that point were you thinking i might
leave single or was that you were
totally head over heels for zach then
no i think again i think it goes back to
the fantasy sweet thing when you start
talking about
like you just have conversations and at
that point it's weird for me to vocalize
oh well
you know this relationship is there and
this relationship is there it's just
maybe i was in my head a little bit and
i was just like
like just taking it all in other than
that no i was still filling everything
out
well i have to ask you one tough
question and i'm gonna ask it quickly so
then we can move on um
but you know of course we've watched you
all season long talk about
your divorce and things you went through
there and and we saw you this week talk
about oh your dad being there for you in
that moment in the car when you were
crying
you opened up so much to everybody um
your ex has spoken out about things
and i was just wondering if you guys
have talked where you're at with that
and how you're feeling about how
everything's played out
um you know i think i've said it before
like my journey is my journey and
um i respect his perspective of how
everything went
and at the end of the day i hope he
finds his happiness and he's doing well
and i know i am and that's that's all i
have to say
um a lot of people zach i don't know if
you've seen this have
uh likened you to matthew mcconaughey
hey and
taysha that's your celebrity crush right
so you know
have you found your celebrity crush in
real life
essentially yeah i have and he even said
all right all right all right
during the episode i will take matt i
will take matt i'll take a poor man's
matthew mcconaughey i'll take whatever
however they want to
associate me with that man i'm like he's
a he's a bad bad dude and i'm here for
it
have you have you gotten that before i
a couple times in my life but not you
know obviously i'm a little bit more out
in front now
i don't know can i get it all right all
right all right
i think i retired now you're putting him
on the spot he's getting
better um tasha as much fun
and just so emotional as your season was
to watch
it also got emotional with some tough
topics with uh the black lives matter
movement
with mental health how would you advise
future contestants and leads to continue
to
tackle those discussions and address
stuff like that on camera and on the
show
i mean i would just say just to like be
honest like if you're feeling like
you want to know more about their lives
like ask the questions like i think
just the sense of security that you can
give to somebody just being like i'm
here for you and
your story matters to me and like just
creating that
level of trust i think allows people to
open up
and i think that those conversations are
so important to have
because down the road they're going to
come out eventually and um
you never know it could really like bond
you guys between all of them but i just
feel like
just be honest and ask the tough
questions i guess
she's not giving herself enough credit i
don't know
the reason those conversations happen is
because tasha you know
is tasha you know and she people felt
comfortable to bring those things to the
table and it was
it's a testament to her i mean i know
for me my experience like
if i wasn't comfortable sharing
something like with her i wouldn't have
shared some things i did
and i think people were glad the show
went there this season did you feel that
way
i think so yeah i think the world needed
it i feel like this has been such a
tough year and like
people are looking for companionship and
something to relate to
no one's looking for like the perfect
life picture anymore it's
it's about being real and relatable
so all right i gotta wrap with you guys
but my last question tasha anything you
would have done differently this season
and reflecting on that what's your
advice for matt james
i would not change a thing i would not
change a thing
um and what's my advice for matt james
is to trust your gut
because it's always right and just be
yourself and you got it
best proposal ever zach that's what
people were saying last night you
crushed it
[Laughter]